alex clearly it's had a lasting effect
on people
um so at what moment did you realize the
first movie was
just such a phenomenon um well the we
made the first movie
uh and then uh the studio that we made
it for went bankrupt and it was shelved
and keanu and i were told it was never
going to come out ever uh and so we had
kind of moved on taking a deep breath
and said okay well that was a fun
experience uh and then it suddenly got
picked up and kind of put out
uh and i think i was in austin shooting
a music video
the weekend that it came out and uh
i walked into like a roadhouse i think
just to get like a
water or something i wasn't eating there
and the whole place like
hundreds of picnic tables just went nuts
um us texans we love it
looking over my shoulder um
and uh yeah and and i've been running
from it ever since
running to it do it do it yeah sorry yes
yes
so kyani what about you because i mean i
know a lot of times you know
in our careers all of us here you'll be
in the bubble of something and you'll
not really realize the impact of it or
how broad that the scope like how broad
its reach is
um what what about you when did you kind
of first realize this is like a big deal
i think it's when you're just walking
when you're kind of just walking down
the street and people are yelling out of
cars at you
yeah dude the excellent party
party yeah that's me you know that right
that i'm the one doing that
yeah they've paid your family to make
you feel good about yourself